Prof: I want to return
briefly to "desenga
ño,"
because there may be some
confusion caused by
"disillusionment,"
the English word used to
translate the term,
which is an approximation as
all translations are.
"Disillusionment"
can mean in English
"disenchantment"
and "disappointment,"
words that have a very negative
connotation whereas,
"desenga
ño"
does not quite have that
connotation.
At worst, it could mean
"resignation,"
meaning,
I was resigned to find out that
such-and-such a person was not
as good as I thought him or her
to be.
Remember the quote from Otis
Green that I read you,
in which "desenga
ño"
was thought of as the summum
bonum,
the ultimate good desired by
the stoic wise man.
Baroque desengaño
is a positive condition at which
the individual arrives after
having shed the scales from his
eyes--
remember?--and learned of the
deceitfulness of appearances of
the mystifying allure of all
that he has taken as being very
valuable.
Everything that shines is not
gold,
is what the individual learns,
having gone through the process
of engaño,
that is deceit and
desengaño,
to put it in the simplest of
terms.
What I suggested,
moreover, is that the plot of
the Quixote and that of
some of these stories embedded
in it in this Part II go through
a similar unfolding from
engaño to
desengaño.
We will be following this
development in the episodes that
we will be dealing with during
the rest of the semester,
some of which are the
culminating episodes in the
entire book,
not only of the second part,
but the entire Quixote.
But let us first turn our
attention today to two critics
whose essays you are reading
this week in the
Casebook,
and this is sort of the
highlight, or the high point,
I should say,
of the Casebook,
these two essays by Auerbach
and Spitzer.
Now, we already saw Auerbach's
main thesis in Mimesis,
his famous book,
and that that thesis is about
the Christian mixture of the
sublime and the low style in the
New Testament,
and how this led to the
emergence and development of
realism and eventually to the
novel and to a book like the
Quixote.
This mixture of the sublime and
low style was a break away from
the strict separation between
high and low style in the
classical tradition which
Auerbach derives--
this idea--from St.
Augustine and the church
fathers, the patristic
tradition.
Auerbach labels sermo
humilis--I put it on the
board--or humble sermon,
or better, humble discourse.
This Christian response to the
classical division of styles
derived--
that division of
styles--derived from Aristotle
and from Roman rhetorical
theory.
This mixture of the
transcendent and the low style
was exemplified by Christ's
passion,
through which the drama of
man's every day life assumes the
most profound meaning:
life does not end in the brief
span of worldly existence;
eternity is present in the
passion as a message of hope.
Now, Auerbach's application of
this theory to the
Quixote leads him to the
belief that the Quixote
is essentially a funny book,
as you have read the essay,
"The Enchanted
Dulcinea"
an interpretation for which
Auerbach was excoriated by
Hispanists,
particularly,
Spanish ones,
for whom the Quixote was
a very profound and
transcendental book.
Although many were motivated by
a nationalistic interpretation
of Cervantes,
whom they saw as the highest
example of Spanish genius,
and his protagonist as the very
representative of the
fatherland,
they were not entirely wrong in
their reactions.
What happened in Spain was that
the Quixote was
canonized,
meaning, turned into a classic
in the eighteenth century,
and then, by the early
nineteenth century,
during the romantic period,
it was exalted as the highest
point of Spanish genius and the
highest representative of the
Spanish language,
in which the spirit of
Spanishness was embedded,
and so forth,
and this was a very
nationalistic reading of the
Quixote that prevailed,
and still prevails,
in some quarters.
And so, the people who held
this view of the Quixote,
of course, were outraged by
Auerbach's reading of the
Quixote as essentially a
funny book.
They were not entirely wrong in
their reactions.
It should be very clear to
those of you reading the
Quixote that there is a
great deal that is very deep and
serious in it both about life
and general and about
literature.
Auerbach's analysis,
however, is very revealing of
how the low style,
particularly in Sancho and
other low class characters plays
such a crucial role in the
farcical episodes in the
Quixote.
Besides, we are not familiar in
the modern period any more with
this separation of styles,
of high and low styles or
anything like that,
and it's very instructive to
read Auerbach,
who was steeped in that,
even when he goes astray,
in my view.
I was criticized by some
Hispanists for having included
that essay in the
Casebook,
by the way, mostly because they
had not been included.
Auerbach's problem is that he
cannot get out of his scheme,
which equates seriousness only
with tragedy.
Don Quixote can be serious
without being tragic,
and, in fact,
this is one of his most
important lessons and most
innovative qualities,
one of the most innovative
qualities of the new literature
that emerges in the wake of
the Quixote.
To say that Cervantes does not
deal with the serious issues of
his time is pure nonsense,
as we have seen.
To claim that the book is,
above all, a farce is also
nonsense.
Besides, a novel's worth should
not be gauged by how faithfully
it represents reality,
if such a thing can be gauged
at all.
Auerbach is wrong when he says
that Don Quixote's
idée fixe has no
contact with reality,
and that it only causes
confusion.
On the contrary,
his idée fixe
serves by contrast to clarify
many things around him,
but there are salvageable parts
of Auerbach's essay,
which is why I included it in
the Casebook.
Nabokov, on the other hand,
the great Russian novelist,
has a horrible book on the
Quixote,
which was a series of lectures
that he gave at Harvard.
And the book is interesting
only because Nabokov wrote it,
but he says really outrageous
things like there is no
reflection of the Spain of
Cervantes' time in the
Quixote.
What?
Nabokov was a great writer,
but not a great critic,
obviously.
I think that the first
salvageable thing in Auerbach's
essay is his reaction against
romantic criticism and the
tendency to over interpret,
whatever that means, ultimately.
Auerbach writes defining his
own position the following--you
have it in the Casebook,
page 58:
"For centuries, [he says]--
and especially since the
romanticists--
many things have been read into
him [into Cervantes]
which he hardly foreboded,
let alone intended.
Such transforming and
transcendent interpretations are
often fertile.
A book like Don Quixote
disassociates itself from its
author's intention and leads a
life of its own.
Don Quixote shows a new
face to every age which enjoys
him.
Yet the historian--whose task
[meaning himself]
it is to define the place of a
given work in historical
continuity--
must endeavor insofar as that
is possible,
to attain a clear understanding
of what the book meant to its
author and his
contemporaries."
Unquote.
This is the dream of the
philologians and the critics
steeped in philology,
that they can actually get back
to the meaning of the work in
the period in which he was
writing and to discern what the
author's intentions were.
We are not so sure any more.
Peter Russell's book--Peter
Russell was an English hispanist
of some note;
his book is called Don
Quixote as a Funny Book--
follows Auerbach and is among
those who styled themselves as
the hard school of Cervantes
criticism,
based mostly in England,
and whose hardness is mostly of
the intellectual arteries,
in my view.
Just because Cervantes
contemporaries found the book
funny,
or just because of what
Cervantes said about the comic,
it is impoverishing to see
the Quixote in this
light,
particularly when the comic is
not defined.
If the comic arises,
as it does in the
Quixote,
from the toils of a mind out of
sorts with the modern world,
then it is a comic of the
highest form of seriousness.
Comedy can be very serious and
profound, and it is in the
Quixote.
Contemporaries often misread
works written in their time,
obviously, and authors'
intentions are very,
very difficult to ascertain,
and I'll say a little bit more
about that later.
Spitzer, Leo Spitzer,
was another great critic of the
German philological school.
He, too, escaped from Nazi
Germany, and preceded Auerbach
in the chair at the University
of Istanbul.
Spitzer wound up at Johns
Hopkins University;
not at Yale,
alas, like Auerbach.
Spitzer was known to be
irascible and belligerent in the
defense of his points of view,
and wrote vicious reviews of
the books with which he
disagreed.
For example,
Stephen Gilman's book on The
Celestina was shredded by
Spitzer in an angry review.
Spitzer was more thoroughly
grounded in philology and
linguistics than Auerbach.
He was a philologist and a
linguist, and spoke many modern
languages and knew practically
all of the classical ones.
He was a very,
very, very learned man,
and very brilliant.
Spitzer believes that one can
get at the core of a work of
literature by going from
something marginal on the
periphery,
like a detail,
and pursuing it all the way to
its center;
that a detail can,
if properly analyzed,
yield a comprehensive
interpretation of the work.
The geometric metaphors
periphery, circle,
center, are a bit naïve
here.
We use metaphors in writing
theory and in writing criticism,
and his are a bit naïve
when we think about them.
We learned to look for
metaphors in criticism through
the work of the great
deconstructionist Paul de Man,
who was a professor here at
Yale.
So the geometric metaphors are
a bit naïve as is Spitzer's
emphasis on discovering the
personality of the author or his
worldview,
his Weltanschauung to
use the German word;
he wants to get at the
psychology of the author.
These are approximations that
Michel Foucault--I think I have
mentioned him;
he is a French philosopher and
theoretician,
whose most famous book is
Les mots et les choses,
in English translated as The
Order of Things,
and the first three chapters on
Hispanic things;
one on Velázquez,
Las Meninas;
one on Cervantes;
and the beginning is on Borges,
the Argentine writer.
These are approximations,
and Michel Foucault would argue
that one limits the possible
meanings of a work by reducing
it to the alleged intention of
its author.
If you say, these were these
the author's intentions,
you create kind of a fence
around a work,
and there can be no meanings
beyond what you assume those
intentions to be.
But I believe that what Spitzer
is trying to find is the
Cervantean,
it's what I call the
Cervantean, which to him is a
point of confluence between form
and content that makes for a
coherent overarching meaning.
Since language is,
after all, the primary material
of a literary work,
I believe that Spitzer's work
is a good lesson to critics who
would leap to hasty
interpretations without a
detailed knowledge of the text.
Now, that language is the
primary material of a literary
work might seem obvious,
but it is a very complicated
statement to make,
because one could say that
paint is the primary material of
painting,
and that doesn't get you very
far.
In the case of language I think
that it does,
not as far as Spitzer would
believe, but I think that it
does.
In the case of the
Quixote, Spitzer
accomplishes his task by
meticulous work on polynomasia.
You have these words in your
essays, so I don't have to put
them on the board,
I know that they are
jawbreakers: polynomasia,
multiple names;
and polyetymology,
multiple origins of words,
meaning multiplicity of names
and multiplicity of word origins
that are present in the scenes
that he analyzes.
Spitzer equates the
multiplicity implicit in these--
in the words--to the
perspectivism inherent in the
interplay of varied views in the
novel by various characters.
Various characters and various
different points of view,
and this is reflected in the
multiplicity of etymologists and
in the multiplicity of names
given to characters and to
things.
The differences of opinion
among the characters is evinced
through the use of language.
The key term in the novel is
the portmanteau word Sancho uses
to mediate in the dispute about
the barber's basin,
the "baciyelmo,"
or the basin helmet,
in English, by which he
attempts to convey the
conflicting points of view about
the object.
According to Webster's,
a portmanteau word,
and James Joyce was famous for
making them up,
is a word that is a combination
of two other words in form and
meaning,
like the word "smog,"
which is a combination of
"smoke"
and "fog."
I bet you didn't know that:
"smoke"
and "fog"
give you "smog,"
and that is a portmanteau word.
Joyce uses them in funny ways,
a passenger in Joyce is the
"pas encore,"
which in French means "not
yet."
Of course, a
"passenger"
is a "pas
encore"
because he hasn't gotten there
yet,
and this is the kind of thing
that Joyce does.
So that's a portmanteau word,
and a
"baciyelmo,"
basin helmet,
is a portmanteau word.
Now, you remember that Spitzer
makes quite a bit of that.
But Spitzer argues behind his
multiplicity there is Cervantes,
the creator of this whole
artistic machine.
He stands over all of the games
of authorship and all of the
ironies.
That is, you can think of it as
Cervantes,
and then all of the polynomasia
and all of the polyetymology and
all that,
but they are contained in this
figure of Cervantes,
the author, who is the author
of all of the ironies and all of
these games.
Cervantes, Spitzer argues,
is no relativist when it comes
to morals--
we saw this already--and
perspectivism and irony are
inherent in a Christian
position,
which is humble by definition,
meaning I don't know enough,
I will never know enough, too.
Behind Cervantes,
the creator,
there is God,
whom Cervantes never denies.
So there will be God above
Cervantes.
Spitzer provides a convincing
historical scheme.
During the Middle Ages,
there is a correspondence
between word and things,
names and characters,
and this is so in the readings
of scripture.
In the Renaissance that is a
word-world, a world of words,
to use my own portmanteau word.
A world of words,
one connecting or leading to
the next by metonymy,
and a world-book,
a world made up of books,
like Alonso Quijano's,
who, as a result,
becomes Don Quixote by
inhabiting that book world or
that world of books.
In the Baroque there is a
phantasmagoria of words that are
like dreams and reveal the
deceit of the world,
including that of language.
Here, in this world of
desengaño is where
we find Cervantes,
particularly the Cervantes of
1615.
So I put these things on the
board because I like you to have
clear ideas.
So Middle Ages,
Renaissance and Baroque;
correspondence:
word things,
words to words and then words
who are deceitful and purveyors
of engaño,
and then leading to
desengaño.
Now, I am very interested,
because I think it is useful
for us as readers and as
students of literature in the
Cervantean,
according to Auerbach and
Spitzer--to me the most
interesting part of Auerbach's
essay is ultimately when he
tries to define the Cervantean,
"lo
cervantino,"
which can be compared with
Spitzer's effort to come to a
similar overall view.
Theoreticians and critics can
say that there is no such thing
as the Cervantean,
yet, there is.
You know, if you have read
the Quixote and you know
literary history,
you know what belongs to the
Cervantes world.
Or a great writer creates a
world of his or her own,
it's a set of plots,
ideas, tropes,
that has some coherence and
that can be identified.
If you have read Proust,
you know what I mean.
You read one proustian
sentence, his long flowing
sentences, and you know
immediately you're reading
Proust.
You read a sentence by Borges,
with his refined irony,
and you know you're reading
Borges,
or you read: "Years later,
before the firing squad Colonel
Aureliano Buendia was to
remember that remote afternoon
when his grandfather took him to
see ice."
This is the beginning of One
Hundred Years of Solitude,
and you know.
Now, Auerbach in defining the
Cervantean begins by giving up.
He says: "The 'peculiarly
Cervantean' cannot be described
in words."
He begins by giving up.
But then he says:
"First of all it is
something spontaneously sensory:
a vigorous capacity for the
vivid visualization of very
different people in very varied
situations,
for the vivid realization and
expression of what thoughts
enter their minds,
what emotions fill their hearts
and what words come to their
lips."
You have to remember that these
quotes from Auerbach were
originally written in German,
and German prose is very
complicated,
and it shows in the translation.
Later, he says:
"And just as sensory is
his capacity [Cervantes']
to think up or hit upon ever
new combinations of people and
events."
I think he's right,
when he says something like
that.
He goes back,
Auerbach goes back to the idea
of the mad gentleman running
into people,
and he says:
"What attracted Cervantes
was the possibility [this
formula]
offered for multifariousness
and effects of perspective,
the mixture of the fanciful and
every day elements in the
subject,
its malleability,
elasticity, adaptability."
Unquote.
He finally proclaims the
following: "[The
Cervantean]
is an attitude--
an attitude towards the world,
and hence also towards the
subject matter of his art--
in which bravery and equanimity
play a major part.
Together with the delight he
takes in the multifariousness of
his sensory play there is in him
a certain southern [here meaning
Southern European,
not Faulknerian south]
reticence and pride.
This prevents him from taking
the play very seriously.
He looks at it;
he shapes it;
he finds it diverting;
it is also intended to afford
the reader refined intellectual
diversion."
Unquote.
He goes back over this.
He says: "The theme of the
mad country gentleman who
undertakes to revive
knight-errantry gave Cervantes
an opportunity to present the
world as play,
in that spirit of multiple
perspective,
non-judging and even
non-questioning neutrality,
which is a brave form of
wisdom."
There is something,
I think, also quite perceptive
there.
That is, that Cervantes is like
a puppet master,
like Master Pedro in the
episode you're about to read,
and he presents all of these
many different characters in
action,
and sort of stands back without
passing judgment.
Now, Spitzer,
on the other hand,
concludes the following:
"This means that,
in our novel,
things are represented not for
what they are in themselves,
but only as things spoken about
or thought about;
and this involves breaking the
narrative presentation into two
points of view.
There can be no certainty about
the 'unbroken' reality of
events;
the only unquestionable truth
on which the reader may depend
is the will of the artist who
chose to break up a multivalent
reality into different
perspectives.
In other words,
perspectivism suggests the
existence of an Archimedean
principle [something on which
the whole thing rests]
outside the plot [he goes on]--
and the Archimedes must be
Cervantes himself."
Unquote.
And one more quote:
"And we may see in
Cervantes' two-fold treatment of
the problem of nicknames
[polynomasia]
another example of this baroque
attitude,
what is true,
what is a dream?--this time,
toward language [language
itself].
Is not human language,
also, vanitas vanitatum?
[vanity of vanities,
what I was saying about the
Baroque language is a
phantasmagoria]."
This is the end of Spitzer's
synthesis, his conclusion after
this very thorough and brilliant
analysis of the novel.
This is my view--I have been
expressing it already--this is
my view both on Auerbach and
Spitzer.
In the glorification of the
author, Spitzer does not take
into account Cervantes' errors.
His famous oversights which
bespeak of a flawed creator,
not God-like in any sense,
hence, pushing the whole issue
of point of view to the edge of
the abyss of madness,
since the final authority is
flawed.
Moreover, Cervantes plays so
much with the author's lack of
authority that one has finally
to take him at face value and
agree that not even he has the
final authority of the book that
we read.
And I think this,
he would have agreed with,
and we have seen it in our
readings of many passages.
The same is true for Auerbach.
My answer, as you will see in
my essays, is Ginés
cross-eyedness.
Remember that Ginés is a
figure of the author,
and a figure of the modern
author.
He has pawned his book,
he wants to make money from it,
he's from the low classes.
He's cross-eyed and this
reveals that there is
perspectivism from within an
assumed single self.
That is, that this figure of
the author here,
cannot be in possession of the
truth because being cross-eyed--
I don't know if I can make
enough cross-eyed--
here, his view of reality is
flawed and conflictive.
Conflictive because there are
two eyes,
not a single point of view,
and this author figure being
cross-eyed makes literally that
his two eyes means two different
visions.
We will talk about that,
when we talk about the puppet
play that Ginés de
Pasamonte puts on,
here in Part II.
So the author is multiple
within himself,
his eyes work independently of
each other,
as it were, he is congenitally
incapable of providing a single
point of view.
Now we turn to the assigned
episodes in the Quixote.
As we turn to these episodes,
let me remind you that I will
be looking into how much each
resembles an episode in Part I,
to what extent these episodes
are rewritings of others that
have all ready taken place in
the first book.
Also, we will see that a
running thread through these
episodes is doubling,
the appearance of doubles of
Don Quixote, of reflections of
Don Quixote.
The first is the episode that
is called, in Jarvis,
"The Episode of the Knight
of the Looking-Glasses,"
which makes it very awkward for
me to say because,
of course, this is eighteenth
century English,
and the English say
looking-glass for a mirror,
and I say Knight of the
Looking-Glasses just to be
consistent with the translation
that you are reading this time
around,
but it's in Spanish
"Caballero de los
espejos,"
"Knight of the
Mirrors."
Now, this episode brings to
mind that of the fight of Don
Quixote with the Basque in Part
I, because you do have an actual
dual.
The most significant aspect of
this episode is that in it,
Don Quixote meets his mirror
image and defeats that mirror
image.
Carrasco has decided that the
only way to subject Don Quixote
is to meet him at his own level
but mostly,
what he is doing is reenacting
Part I in the way that Don
Quixote reenacted--
and still reenacts--the
romances of chivalry.
Don Quixote will fight a copy
of himself modeled after his own
mad inventions,
a copy that is reach in
details.
Notice that Dulcinea here is
Casildea de Vandalia.
Vandalia means Andalusia,
land of Vandals;
the Vandals were one of the
Germanic tribes that invaded the
peninsula after the collapse,
or with the collapse,
of the Roman Empire.
Carrasco's get up as a
knight-errant is quite
something.
He has outdone Don Quixote and
here is a quote from page 554:
"Don Quixote viewed his
antagonist,
and found he had his helmet on,
and the beaver down,
so that he could not see his
face: but he observed him to be
a strong-made man,
and not very tall.
Over his armor he wore a kind
of surtout,
or loose coat,
seemingly of the finest gold,
besprinkled with sundry little
moons of resplendent
looking-glass,
which made a most gallant and
splendid show.
A great number of green,
yellow, and white feathers
waved about his helmet."
Unquote.
This translation or the
translation struggles a bit with
the "lunas,"
the word used for mirrors in
the original,
"muchas lunas de
resplandecientes
espejos,"
which contains,
that word, a most important
suggestion in the passage.
La "luna del
espejo"
is the reflecting part of the
mirror.
But "luna"
means "moon,"
of course, and moon leads to
lunacy, to madness.
Sansón is the Knight of
the Moons,
the Knight of Lunacy,
the Knight of Madness,
which is quite appropriate
because in trying to cure Don
Quixote's madness,
he is acting like a madman,
like a lunatic.
The moon, of course,
is also the celestial body of
reflected light par excellence,
the same as the Knight of the
Looking-Glasses,
Sansón in this get up,
is a reflection of Don Quixote.
If Don Quixote came close
enough to Sansón,
he would be able to see himself
reflected on the little mirrors.
As in the episode of the
parliament of death,
Don Quixote has met a mirror
image of his madness here.
It is more than just a
reflection, that is,
he is reflected in the Knight
of the Moons who is acting like
him,
and he is also reflected in his
armor,
being reflected back from those
little mirrors on his costume,
so you can see.
Sancho has also met his double
in Tomé
Cecial,
whose false nose is a
prodigious example of the
grotesque,
which is such a prevalent
quality in Part II.
I quote: "...
scarcely have the clearness of
the day given opportunity to see
and distinguish objects,
when the first thing that
presented itself to Sancho's
eyes,
was the Squire of the Wood's
nose, which was so large,
that it almost overshadowed his
whole body.
In a word, it is said to have
been of an excessive size,
hawked in the middle,
and full of warts and
carbuncles,
of the color of a mulberry,
and hanging two fingers'
breadth below his mouth.
The size, the color,
the carbuncles,
and the crookedness,
so disfigured his face,
that Sancho,
at sight thereof,
began to tremble hand and foot,
like a child in a fit,
and resolved within himself to
take two hundred cuffs before
his choler should awaken to
encounter that hobgoblin."
He may have thought that he had
to fight this fellow as the two
masters would fight and he is
saying,
after seeing that nose,
I would never,
never fight this monster.
Notice the exaggerated
dimensions and utter hideousness
of the nose, which together with
its being artificial and new
features of Part II.
Maritornes was naturally ugly,
and though her physical
deformities were extreme,
they are at least her own,
and not likely to inspire fear
so much as repulsion.
But here Sancho is moved to
dread, which will happen often
in Part II: fear is one of the
emotions that we encounter once
and again in Part II,
and you can begin charting them
from now on.
Tomé Cecial's nose is
connected to the aesthetics of
the Baroque whose emblematic
figure is the monster,
a figure made up of disparate
conflicting elements,
like the nose,
and contrived to cause
admiration.
The monster is made to be
shown, and this quality is
embedded in the very etymology
of the word "monster,"
"monstrare,"
in the Latin.
Don Quixote has met in the
Knight of the Looking-Glasses an
image of his madness;
in Tomé
Cecial, Sancho has met an image
of his foolishness.
Tomé is like a carnival
figure of the fool and his
costume is reminiscent of those
of the actors in the wagon of
the parliament of death.
His name is a pun:
Tomé Cecial,
"Tomé,"
of course, is a form of
Tomás,
Thomas;
but Cecial, at the time,
meant a kind of
"trout."
So "tomé,"
being the past,
his name means "I ate
trout" if you step back and
think of it.
There are many names that mean
something and you don't catch on
to it until you think about it,
but this is,
scholars have come up with
identifying that,
Tomé Cecial, I ate trout.
Now, the fact that Tomé
is an image of Sancho's
foolishness is so much so
because Tomé
is Sancho's neighbor,
his equal, with whom Sancho
discourses on things proper to
squires and whose gluttony and
other habits he shares.
The dialogue about the
contingency of meaning and
language,
centering on "hijo de
puta"
or "whore's son"
is hilarious,
but bespeaks of a very modern
conception of language,
as Spitzer mentions somewhere
in his essay,
that is meaning is contingent
in language,
it is not fixed,
it is shifty,
and this is consistent with the
view of the Middle Ages,
Renaissance and Baroque--in the
Baroque is shiftiness,
as language is emphasized.
So in the dialogue of the
squires there is also a critique
of the upper classes,
a frequent topic in Part II,
that you might also chart as
you read it.
They, particularly Sancho,
do not accept the codes of
chivalry that lead to such
fights.
Sancho seems to be saying that
it is the upper classes that
start wars, a very deep
critique.
This is part of the political
element of the second book,
of the 1615 Quixote,
but also fits in within
thematics of the
desengaño,
because the accoutrements of
the upper classes,
their luxuries,
are part of the deceits that
are undone by
desengaño,
as you will see as you move
through the upper classes in the
next few episodes.
Now, what is the significance
of all of this doubling?
Don Quixote meets a double,
Sancho meets a double,
I think that at the deepest
level it means that the
characters have met themselves,
and struggled each within
himself to find meaning and
identity,
or identity within meaning,
or a form of wise self
recognition,
troubled self recognition.
This is tied to the issue of
self-reflexivity that we have
been discussing since the
beginning.
If the Renaissance mind,
the mind of the Renaissance,
if I my use an abstraction,
sallies forth in search of the
real world,
which it tries to interpret,
control and use,
the Baroque mind,
in that sallying forth,
finds mostly itself,
it finds its own inner
workings.
This is equate to Descartes,
"Je pense,
donc je suis,"
"Cogito ergo
sum,"
"I think therefore I
am," which is the ultimate
truth that Descartes can
find–Descartes,
1596-1650 roughly contemporary
a little later than Cervantes--
but it is a self recognizable
yet disfigured in these images,
in need of further and further
thought and reflection with the
emphasis on reflection on like a
mirror.
It is appropriate,
then, for these reasons,
that the characters should meet
distorted images of their own
selves,
or twisted reflections of
themselves in their adventures.
Sansón Carrasco has
fallen into his own trap while
Don Quixote and Sancho have an
almost literally out of body
experience seeing themselves
outside of themselves,
and seeing themselves how they
would look to others.
This is particularly troubling
to,
I think, Sancho,
but also to Don Quixote who,
as the novel progresses,
will find more such instances
where reflections of this kind
undermine his quest.
Saying so, we move on to the
episode of the lions,
which is reminiscent of that of
the galley slaves in Part I.
The lions, like the prisoners,
are prisoners,
and they belong to the king;
they are also under the
supervision of the crown.
Finding lions in the middle of
Castile is not a common
occurrence,
so their appearance is another
instance of the real conspiring
to add to Don Quixote's madness
by presenting him with beings
and objects that are out of the
ordinary.
Like the players in the cart,
lions are objects of
amusements,
they are being taken to courts
so they can viewed by the
people,
amusement and display.
They are fit for heroic action,
and Don Quixote does act with
great courage only to be mocked
by the lion,
that not only acts peacefully
but turns his hindquarters to
the knight;
the ultimate insult:
heroism is no longer possible
under these circumstances.
It is a very cruel episode for
Don Quixote,
but together with the fight
with the Knight of the
Looking-Glasses,
these are two victories for Don
Quixote,
which together with the
knowledge that is now in a book,
add to his diluted sense of
importance and of
accomplishments.
The characters around him
conspire to increase this
delusion, but the lions are real
and could have killed Don
Quixote and the others.
Jorge Luis Borges,
whom I have quoted so many
times in this course,
the great Argentine writer,
says that courage is the one
characteristic that is a
constant from book one to book
two;
the courage of Don Quixote,
and it is also the constant
from Alonso Quijano to Don
Quijote and back to Alonso
Quijano at the end of the book.
And so we come to the gentleman
in green, the gentleman in the
Green Riding-coat.
In Don Diego de Miranda,
Don Quixote meets another
double, but an inverted one,
like a mirror image.
Don Diego de Miranda appears to
be the hidalgo Don Quixote would
have been had he not read
romances of chivalry,
turned mad, and chosen to
attempt to revive the age of
chivalry.
He is like the Knight of the
Looking-Glasses,
another distorted reflection of
Don Quixote, the one,
I repeat, that he could have
been.
Don Diego is the image of what
the French, in the period,
called the honnête
homme.
He is reasonably well off,
reads devotional books,
hunts, and lives an honest
peaceful life at home.
Don Quixote mocks him,
slightly in the episode of the
lions,
when Don Diego prudently runs
away,
and again, as he takes his
leave, telling him that he is
not--
Don Quixote says he is not
giving to leisure,
like Don Diego.
Don Diego is a kind of
pre-bourgeois character,
but he has a son who wants to
be a poet Lorenzo de Miranda.
We have, once again,
the post-prandial conversation,
and one more time,
the discussion centers in the
relative merits of arms and
letters.
This is a repetition of that
episode,
but now in a well appointed
house not in a dilapidated inn,
and Don Quixote has
interlocutors who are on his
intellectual level.
Lorenzo is quite a good poet,
who reminds us of
Grisóstomo and Cardenio,
but does not take action as
they did.
Don Quixote reveals that he
knows a great deal about poetry,
but the outcome of the exchange
is that chivalry surpasses
poetry,
that arms are superior to
letters.
This whole section seems to be
in homage of Garcilaso de la
Vega,
the great Spanish poet of the
sixteenth century,
whose name I've mentioned many
times,
and who has become by this time
the model of poet,
courtier and soldier.
Garcilaso, who lived in the
first half of the sixteenth
century died while attempting to
scale the wall of a castle
during a battle in Charles the
Fifth's army;
they dropped a rock on him.
He only lived thirty-six years,
but his poetry changed the
course of poetry in Spanish
forever.
Cervantes was quite devoted to
him.
The discussion turns to the
issue of if a poet can be made
or if he is born,
and this, again,
is another example of Don
Quixote's extensive readings of
other than merely books of
chivalry.
This is the library beyond the
library that was burnt by the
priest and the barber and the
women at Don Quixote's house.
And then we come to the last
episode I'll be discussing
today, which is a transition
episode to Camacho's wedding.
This is the episode of the
swordsmen, the two swordsmen who
begin to argue about who's
better.
One is very,
very strong,
and the other is one is an
expert, a scientist of fencing.
At this time,
since the advent of firearms
and all of that,
fencing had become a sport,
and not only a sport but a
science.
There were books written about,
trying to understand fencing in
geometric and mathematical
terms, and Cervantes liked to
poke fun at this.
However, it is the scientific
swordsman who makes a fool out
of the other one,
who is so strong that,
at the end, when he is very
angry he takes his sword and
throws it so far away that it
takes a long time to get out
there and pick it up.
The point of this throwaway
episode in the scene is that it
shows that art triumphs over
nature,
that science triumphs over
strength,
and the triumph of art over
nature is a baroque topic that
appears once and again
throughout Part II.
And we are going to be talking
about that in the next class,
when we talk about Camacho's
wedding in relation to a
painting by Velázquez
called The Spinners,
Las hilanderas.
But now we have to turn and to
conclude to our Exemplary
Story, The Glass
Graduate,
which I hope that you have
read.
We have gone over the 1613
Exemplary Stories book,
how Cervantes published it,
because publishers became
interested in his work after the
success of the 1605
Quixote.
Also, once he realized that he
couldn't use these stories,
which he had in the way he used
them in Part I because he had
been so criticized--
and you have read about the
criticisms as they appear at the
beginning of Part II,
so Cervantes,
who prided himself on being the
first to ever write this kind of
novella in the Spanish language
collected them in this wonderful
book that would have given
Cervantes a prominent place in
the canon even if he had not
written the Quixote.
Now, The Glass Graduate
is one of the better known
stories famous for the very
strange kind of madness that
afflicts the protagonist.
He believes himself to be made
of glass, and lives in constant
fear of being broken.
It is another example of
Cervantes' profound interest in
the workings of the human mind
and in issues concerning
knowledge and the ability to
arrive at the truth.
Tomás is a very
suggestive sort of paranoia,
it is an illness that has a
kafkaesque air to it.
In Kafka's The
Metamorphosis,
as you know,
the protagonist becomes a
roach;
Tomás suffers a malaise
that is experienced through fear
of bodily harm,
of physical fragility.
It is a way of feeling
different and vulnerable that
can be extended to a general
human condition,
a form of alienation.
I think this is the main reason
why the story is so compelling,
the idea of this madness,
that you feel yourself made of
glass,
and therefore vulnerable,
and you try to establish a
distance between you and the
others,
who might break you or
anything, a tile falling a roof
might break you,
and taking laborious measures
to protect your very vulnerable
body.
Now, the novel begins as if it
were to be a compressed kind of
a bildungsroman--
that's a German word for novel
of education,
"bildung"
education, "bildung
sroman"--
but then it moves on to
encompass Tomás's entire
life.
It is not, however,
a biography,
but it centers on two or three
periods of his life,
most particularly on the one
during his illness.
The plot is circular,
and circularity is expressed
through Tomás's very last
name.
First he is called
"Rodaja,"
his last name is
which means "slice,"
"una rodaja"
is "a slice,"
or not quite a circle,
a fragment of a sphere,
but when he--
at the end--when he recovers
from his illness and is in full
command of his faculties,
his last name becomes
"Rueda"
which means "wheel."
so he has been completed.
We go back to Spitzer and his
polynomasia.
Now, during his illness,
he is known as the
"Licenciado Vidriera"
which is the name of the story
in Spanish,
which means "the
Licentiate Glass Window."
They call him "graduate
glass" in the translation,
but "vidriera"
means a "glass
window,"
a stained glass window,
or a glass display case.
So this is what his name is;
again, we have to go back to
Spitzer and names,
and things, and so forth.
There is something passive
about Tomás,
except when he is ill,
but on the whole,
things happen to him.
He is found lying down under
some trees by the young
gentlemen who take him to
Salamanca;
he is their servant for eight
years,
but also acquires an education
showing a remarkable
intelligence,
though this is only reported,
not dramatized,
until he's ill;
he is always in a second plane
as it were.
As a soldier,
he moves around trying to soak
up as much experience and
culture as possible.
Tomás is then
administered a poison by a
spurned woman,
a spurned woman who is no
courtly damsel,
but a notorious whore,
who falls in love with him.
The poison quince preserve,
"membrillo,"
that she gives him,
is redolent with sexual
connotations,
as in Latin,
in the classics,
the
"membrillo,"
in the original Latin was
associated by way of resemblance
with female sexual organs.
This is how she lures him into
eating it,
but there is no hint of what
makes him attractive to her,
other than perhaps his fame as
a brilliant scholar.
It seems like a whim,
that she falls in love with
him.
She disappears,
and that is far as the erotic
themes goes in the story:
it disappears.
When ill, Tomás displays
a remarkable intelligence and
wit,
being not only insightful in
his observations,
but making these with puns,
sharp witticisms and clever
circumlocutions.
He is oracular,
he is like an Oracle and is
consulted as such by people.
There is a correlation between
his illness and his
insightfulness,
which seems to hinge on
transparency since he believes
himself to be made of glass.
And if you go to page one
thirteen you will find a quote
in which he challenges them to
ask him questions that he will
be able to answer,
but, because he was a man of
glass rather than flesh,
I'm quoting:
"For since glass was a
fine and delicate substance his
mind would function more quickly
and efficiently in that in a
conventional body which was made
of denser and earthlier
stuff."
I mean, his body would be
denser, and glass is transparent
and so forth--this is in page
113.
In other words,
Tomás's mind makes
transparent the world around
him, just as his body is
presumably transparent;
transparency gives him access
to the truth.
But he is also said to be
highly educated and intelligent,
so his insightfulness,
once he is ill,
is like an increase of these
qualities,
or is it disconnected from it?
It is not clear if it was the
poison or the precarious
condition in which he believes
to be that sharpens his wit.
He is like the black man in the
traditional story,
who can tell the emperor that
he is naked because he has
nothing to lose,
because Tomás,
because of his illness,
has become a sort of freak;
he has no reputation to
protect, and so he pierces
through all social convention,
and through hypocrisy and lies,
and tells the truth.
He also, in outlining the
various virtues and defects of
each profession or trade,
is following a traditional
formula,
a set piece that became a skit
in the theater,
too, someone who tells,
well, monks do this,
and cobblers do that;
that is behind this story.
Now, The Glass Graduate
has much in common with the
Quixote and seems to
dramatize the common debate in
that book between arms and
letters because he is both a
soldier and he is a student,
a brilliant student at
Salamanca, a law student.
But whereas Don Quixote is
mainly a reader of literature,
of romances of chivalry above
all, Tomás is a legal
scholar,
whose mission is reaching the
truth.
His quest is more intellectual
than literary,
so, in that sense,
he is not quite like Don
Quixote, he is different,
more philosophical one could
say.
The ending seems to suggest,
as it is throughout the
Quixote,
the preeminence of arms over
letters when he has to escape
from Salamanca and goes back to
Flanders and has a career in the
army and ends his life
honorably.
Now, we will be looking at
other Exemplary Stories
in the near future,
and you will be able to
experience the variety of plots
and narrative experiments that
the book contains and that,
I think, is the reason for its
being--
for these stories--being called
exemplary;
they are like a collection of
samples or examples of plots and
stories.